what's up everybody welcome to the
Future Academy this is the brand new
channel so I hope many of you guys who
are used to seeing us on the regular
channel have made it over you've jumped
over the digital divide on today's
episode of logotherapy we have two brand
new therapists let's get right into it
cuz I know you don't want to hear from
me you want to see what they're doing so
Jonah there we go logotherapy two new
therapists are joining us a marcus
wrench and hadeel Syed Ahmad
they're both joining us doing two logos
there they are you know how this format
works it's two logos two designers today
it's two by two and there they are the
two beautiful lovely therapists that
we're joining us Marcus wrench here's
how you get in touch with them at on
Instagram it's at Marcus underscore
wrench
he's from Hamburg Germany and this is
some of his work some really cool work
he's really good at designing crescent
and line drawings like this and he might
even do some logo grading for us who
knows because I saw some of his work and
also joining us today from Amman Jordan
is hadeel Syed Ahmad and you can find
her on instagram at hadeel s Ahmad and
this is some of her work and you may
recognize some of her work because it's
been talked about or at least mentioned
in some of our subgroups on Facebook you
guys so definitely check her out she's
really good
somebody's a human beatbox over there
okay so up first submitted his work
Stanley V M Stanley very masculine
designer Stanley V M did this logo be
curious and I looked at this I'm very
curious about it it looks pretty good I
like that there's a B and there's a
question mark but Marcus Marcus what do
you need to do with this welcome to the
show Marcus I look at your lighting and
the channel depth of field doing good
all right take us through your process
what are gonna show us so just wanna
show you guys the logo itself as you
mentioned before it got a question mark
that I think we got a problem here when
we don't have the colors so right and we
can just spot the question mark so also
some people who commented in facebook
there
looks more like a than a question log
mm-hmm all I'm saying yeah mm-hmm and so
I thought I'm gonna change double
because the concept itself is works
Kuwait I think yeah so I just played a
video I guess yes so let's get into it
and are you gonna talk over the video
yeah okay cool that's right - so um okay
just I just open it in Photoshop and
doing my sketches usually I don't sketch
digital but I saw it in the recent
episode with smart man I guess from the
Netherlands yes he did this very very
good so I'm gonna show you guys how I
did this in Photoshop because I think
it's just better to show you through the
process you know what for a second there
I was fooled I thought you're doing this
lie it was like hey he's open up
Photoshop guys you're so smooth there's
a long video screen recording right you
just yeah I had it just - this videos
like I think four times faster because
I'm super super slow is that to fasten
it up
yeah I'm just starting to sketching I'm
just trying to hug how could I place the
question like inside to be mm-hmm
I why my sketches are super super messy
so don't you don't you don't judge and
then I was like what if I rotate the
question mark is it still recognizable
mm-hmm I don't know it was like I was
curious and so being curious yeah they
deferred yes I was in what he just used
a different shape with a question mark
because it's like there's like two main
faves of a question mark right mm-hmm
just sent a second it's more rounded now
as you're working through this I just
want to remind everybody it's tuning in
if you're watching us in a classroom or
you're sitting there thinking now I
could do better nut maybe you can maybe
you can't who knows but I do want to say
this thing that the whole point of us
inviting people to come on the show and
even the reason why we do what we do is
just to show you how other people think
through a problem so I think there's
lots to learn whether or not you agree
with the solutions or the decisions
that's been made and I think sometimes
when you see the way somebody works in
this case Marcus was saying how he saw
Mart sketching in Photoshop that gave
him an idea to try in Photoshop to and
so that's the beauty of design when we
share our process with one another we
can learn something right so and this
sketch looks more like a two so I was
like that doesn't work and I was like
what if I take the second sketch and use
the angle but use it kind of a mocha
negative space like you can see this I'm
just trying this so it's it has very
dynamic and there's a lot of going on
here it's like some motion negative
space and this is the sketch I just took
and lit up the shape in Illustrator so I
can just jump a speed where it just
speed it a bit up so you can see
normally I don't I'm not a guy who just
answer sketches and then open it an up
illustrator and trying to build the
construction both sketch because I think
it's messy I'm always trying to do the
proper grading when I'm sketching so
later when I built a shaven illustrator
I know what to do so this is basic what
I just did yeah
you keep talking or you keep you keep
playing the video I just want to welcome
people who are watching us on the
regular Facebook Instagram account just
to make that jump go ahead and do it
right now swipe up is that how you have
set up just a link we got the link in
the chat already okay and those of you
guys that are tuning in live go ahead
and start hitting your questions I think
we have Marc and Jonah and Ricky and
Mike and Bobby and Flynn and Kerri
they're all watching the comments in
Jerry afraid Jerry I'm so sorry Jerry
now you've laid out some lines to kind
of help you guide the angles so that
they're consistent yes I use the
30-degree thirty degrees so I'm just
trying to refine the sketch of it mm-hmm
oh no it's starting to turn into
something here hmm I think I know where
you're going with this mark and I like
the direction because you're using the
negative space to form the question mark
but you're also creating very - dynamic
interlocking shapes I'm concerned that
the question mark is getting lost but
let's see where you take this okay okay
all right all right so just fill this
shape with white because the logo is
mostly used on a black surface so just
try to yep imagine how it would look
like so I'm gonna refine the sketch and
then take the sketch open it up an
illustrator no we are an illustrator and
take the sketch and I always use the
font grid no straighter because I think
it's super comfortable and you can't
just hide hide it and show it yeah yep I
mean you have a great turned on
yeah yeah okay I'm so at this point
you're pretty comfortable there sketch
that you're gonna proceed into
vectorizing it now yeah yeah okay so I'm
just building the cryptic construction
mm-hmm I'm starting with DP I tried to
show you guys what I did with the
circles by moving the mouse cursor
around this yes yes I like I'd like
Jonah cutting in your face there from
time to time that's a good crop there
Jonah nice why thank you Chris I like it
later when you watch his back Marcus
you're like oh that was kind of cool hmm
okay I just put some strokes and a light
aligned and moved two circles and then I
would take them 30 degrees yes so
there's something very soothing at
therapeutic just seeing grid lines in
construction I think there's a designer
thing that's going on here over here
mm-hmm I forgot to ask you Marcus can
you welcome people who are watching us
in Germany in German can you welcome to
the Future and tell them what you're
doing in German of course couldn't talk
after this become through a future
husband excellent eyes guten tag
all right good and our beautiful
ooh now it's starting to get a little
you're offsetting the circle huh yeah
mm-hmm I'm just well I'm just one wedge
to circle a bit so it squeezed it
squeeze it and you were later I did this
okay I think now we got everything to
the other shapes no one just got flipped
two circles
and rotate them 30 degrees I see
mm-hmm everything's on that 30 degree
angle right right yes so so precise so
Germany the best engineers in the world
best cost yeah yes that's right
no doubt I agree so no I got everything
to build to shape I just copied the lair
and now I'm starting with to be very
simple stuff very basic stuff mm-hmm
so you're deleting lines are just moving
them or are you gonna use shape builder
at some point I use the shape a bit of
chocolate some come on okay and then I
just show my construction so a Kenny
life corner to I say and now we got the
B so I Heidi and now I'm just trying to
build the shape of the question mark
that's the harder one to see the draw
yes I I just lines every single life
from hand because you can you could just
use the tape build a true but what I
often experience is that it adds
unnecessary anchor point it does and I
don't like this
I just want those anchor points from
circles you see just clean loose
holiness perfect and I'm just I'm trying
to make sure our DoD his stroke is
perfectly lined with the circle what I
did is um just you can see this just
double-checking so I'm just I'm trying
to mark the anchor point and when
everything shows up I know it's
your line so I can it can be sure
everything is clean I say the Germans
are so precise so precise
now some people were making fun of me
before because they don't understand how
we do this when you take a circle and
you rotate the circle like why is he
rotating a circle it's because you're
actually rotating the anchor points
right so when you first have a circle
the anchor points are north and south
and east and west perfectly at a 90
degree angle from each other but when
you take it and you rotate it you fools
oh no I'm gonna be a good behavior I
told myself I'm not gonna do this you
you find people you find people watching
and I know curious minded you rotate the
circle and then therefore the anchor
points rotate at the 30 degrees and
that's how he's able to get those things
to line up that's right so I think I
just got almost everything to build the
question mark and I just need it like
this one here from the bottom circle so
I try to the last bit I think I made a
super copy of it because I couldn't
remember it probably how I did this in
the first place so okay so what are you
doing right now um you will see okay all
right just your thing shut up watch and
learn keep it down there Chris yeah
don't rush it
[Music]
it's just one line I need so no just
that line right there though I okay I
think that's it so mm-hmm I know I used
the shape builder tool and I was just
checking if it has some unnecessary
anchor points but it didn't so I was
glad mm-hmm so no both shapes and the
dot mm-hmm and now I can subtract the
question mark from the B and used right
corner tools and that's it Wow
there it is ladies and gentlemen look at
that so and the final thing I did next
was just to add some type mm-hmm yeah
you got to integrate the type just gonna
show you guys this circle is the
smallest size of my construction so this
is my X and I used like 2 and 1/2 X for
the spacing so when the type starts I
say very precise it is very precise mark
they don't mess around
Asians I it's kind of like this it kind
of feels right but I'm speaking for most
Asians Vietnamese like myself or just
like Germans were very precise I'm
talking about the jungle Asian
hey Ali Wong man Ali wanna juggle a [ __ ]
she called me a jungle agent luck all
right fine so I think no I just tried to
edit I'm okay it takes like forever okay
[Music]
sorry
he did say he was slow at the beginning
right he he did and as I miss did you
come here are you mm-hmm
it's called Poppins Poppins Provence
mm-hmm Google font and they use it
actually on their website so it's a
nice-looking typeface
it's very clean and when you look at the
eye you see what I did the Burcu I use
this any question mark as well so it
works quite well it's the same size
almost okay it's just just a shape
overall yeah some some sans-serif
typefaces the eyes squared in summer
circular and so it's nice that he found
a typeface that there's some repeating
elements you want to be able to make
those things related to each other
mm-hmm so there you are so the way that
you're working here it almost seems like
you're preparing this for an identity
standards guide while you're doing it
yeah yeah this is perfectly like I would
do it and before we a client okay
awesome now do you have the file can we
see your AI file just like step out of
the QuickTime movie let's just take a
look at the finished thing in black so
that wasn't see that and maybe you can
put the before and after next to each
other for us can you do that did Stanley
give you the vector file the original
thing or he get he did yes by the way
his last name was young wolf excellent
vm stanley vm it is
the AG involve young enough yeah no
phenomena okay no yeah okay all right
let's zoom in there please can we put
them on top of each other like a and B
on top and so that we can get a little
closer into this please okay let's get
let's hide all the pallets and let's
just take a look at this everybody let's
talk about this for a second tell us in
the comments below
do you like what Marcus did do you
prefer the original tell us why don't
just say I like it I hate it that's not
really constructive let's practice the
art of critique in formulating and
articulating our opinion okay
now the original I thought was really
nice it was simple it was bold but it
did have a problem in that he's right
without the colors you cannot read this
and you got to make sure that the mark
can be legible in black and white
because there will be many times when
that's only the option I thought perhaps
a simple outline shadow behind the
question mark could have solved that
trimming a little bit of the hook on the
question mark would make it look less
like the P and that would have solved it
and maybe some tighter integration
between the be curious and the mark
itself for me I think you've just made
the mark smaller that would have worked
now Marcus has taken on a whole
different approach he did several
sketches and he arrived at this kind of
there's a certain style question mark
that looks exactly like the one that
he's put up inside the beat if you
explore your different typefaces you'll
see that and that's why he was able to
do that
I think his his solution is interesting
I'm starting to feel like he's lost a
question mark a little bit but it's an
interesting mark it looks good it's a
nice lock up between those two things
it's just in the exploration maybe we've
lost a little bit I think this would
make an excellent mark for pepto-bismol
because it looks like an intestinal
tract you know and something's going on
there or maybe some liquid plumr
kind of thing like just let's cluck
let's clear up that clog and I think his
tie phase was a very smart choice tie
face and I would recommend to Stanley
maybe look at something where some of
the elements tied together a little bit
more something like that so very good
good job ok let's see so you guys let us
know do you prefer the original or
Marcus's version in the comments I'm
sure he's gonna read them and start
crying instantly and I'm just kidding
to me beg next up next up s is a logo
submitted by Ashraf Lou Boni and he did
or he or she I don't know did a mark for
Sultan coffee I like I like this it's
like nice line drawing icon pretty cool
holy cow what is the deal gonna do with
this market deal welcome to the show Hey
yes hi hi everyone okay so take us
through what you're gonna do give us one
thing oh okay we're still working on
this screen share yeah okay we're good I
see her do you see her yeah fantastic
okay yay you are by way a pioneer you're
the first woman to come on the show as
the logo therapist so congratulations
trailblazing okay now please take us
through your process okay I picked this
logo it's not the direction that I go
for normally so it's like a challenge
for me I usually go for a geometric soil
designs but this is gonna be like an
organic illustration mm-hmm it's very
geometrical for me now so let's go
through the process a deal I'm a little
disappointed
ratha bat I was hoping that you would
wear a giant cup of coffee over your
head I've seen you on Instagram I've
seen you on social media I'm glad I'm
seeing you moving and talking in kind of
real life in front of me so this is
fantastic
thank you Chris okay let's go through
the first video and before we start this
I got the reference picture from
Shutterstock
so I can build the face upon it mm-hmm
that's a good-looking man yes I needed a
mustache and a beard mm-hmm and I like
this the curves of the affair yeah I
took the picture I worked on the levels
so I get the the shadow part over the
face let me start by saying any the logo
is going to be a negative space style
design okay so negative space designs
focuses on the the negative dark shades
of an object not the light the light one
so we built the dark parts there then we
add the light force that's why I made
his face very dark I see you just make
it really high contrast now right yes
exactly
so I started sketching normally I sketch
on paper but for this this episode
episode I sketched on Photoshop mm-hmm
I'm gonna I'm gonna show you also the
sketch on paper okay super okay
sketches are better done with the blue
ink mm-hmm most of the time you should
use a normal brush right now yeah just
the normal brush mm-hmm on another layer
I'm highlighting the the dark areas and
the light areas over the face mm-hmm oh
this is gonna be very interesting how
you do this and you're right this is
very different than normally how you
design your logos yeah yeah I go for
geometrical shapes this is more of an
organic and illustration not my Terrace
but it was a very interesting project to
to challenge myself mm-hmm okay
what was the biggest difference you
notice from sketching and Photoshop
compared to on paper paper you can you
can control the pen more than you do on
on Photoshop
although I do you use a pen this is my
pen I use it all the time
my computer is a touch touchscreen it's
like a welcome but paper and ink gives
you a better feeling of the of the
drawing I don't use pencils I use them
directly I'm gonna show you the hand
hand sketched one but on Photoshop I
needed to trace the the unvectorized the
image I'm gonna fast forward so you're
tracing the contours right now is that
what you're doing yes yes exactly and I
just want to say hello to the 353 people
that are tuning in live I'm excited and
happy to see you because this is a brand
new channel the future Academy so I'm so
glad that you joined us today
well yeah Anna deal you have a I think
you have a lot of fans I think you have
a lot of fans in it so I'm just gonna
say that it's our community designers
Union do you want to say yeah sure so so
say what language do you speak Arabic
Arabic okay could you say something to
them please yeah sure
might have our designers give Halcomb
hip-hop salsa and come Korea's
commercially man and alloyed will hire
that Roberto the Guardian and saw that
mr. Federman height had a mean human
markers or best ally kumano hello but
that was like a whole thing
what'd you say I said all right somebody
will have to tell me later what she said
type it in the job she's like I'm
sitting there these idiots and I'm gonna
show them how did we do it represent
yeah okay so here I was I was drawing
the mustache and a beard
and then I decided I wanted the beer to
have a hint of a coffee bean mmm
so I erased some of the lines also I
didn't want him to have cyanosis beard
[Laughter]
yeah yes
or a ball Sachin is it they said in the
movie mm-hmm okay
no this video I started victimizing the
let me maximize my screen Zhi Zhu Zi Zi
was saying go ha do you might know this
person and then more on more why I said
something in Arabic I can't read a lot
of people technique in there a big yeah
they are saying a lot of fans here yes
we have a huge community we are a
designers union we are the Arabic
community for designers we are more than
90 96,000 Wow
and we're based out of all I already
said yeah we're online
we're on Facebook Google Facebook group
ok yeah it covers designers of all
fields not only graphic designers and
it's directed to Arab designers because
we don't have a community mm-hmm I've
started it three years ago so we're
doing what a union should do because we
don't have unions for designers mm-hmm
big plans for the future in Java I like
that so are you helping them to
understand about best business practices
how to price yes yes yes there are
certain regulations we have done and I'm
going to post the video ok we've done
the minimum twice lists for for every
almost every graphic design and interior
design photography illustrations for
designers not to go under that list
mm-hmm a minimum minimum price yeah
let's get back to the video I'll do it
what I'm doing is I'm Victor rising to
the illustration so I started with with
the guidelines the only the guy
I didn't do a great system I started by
doing a basic geometrical shape
duplicated it and rotated it reflected
it on the vertical and then you're gonna
see how it's going to start shaping off
removing the coronaries so illustrative
logos
fix a lot of time they need like trial
and error you need to make your curves
go very smooth so this is like the rough
first vector version of the illustration
mm-hmm you're gonna see how it ended up
I think I'm gonna do more yeah yeah I
really like the feeling of transferring
and in a sketch to a vector-based logo
mm-hmm so when lines are near horizontal
then you just make them straight right
yeah mm-hmm exactly
we can't fast forwards like sure you're
using the pen tool you just gonna do
this everybody knows how to do this in
theory yes mm-hmm
simple pen tools simple geometrical
shape I like it I'm building the the
black side first the negative side first
sorry the shadows first and then I will
add the white sports okay
let's fast-forward
this is a very rough draft of the victor
I'm going to show you now let us know if
you guys have any questions those guys
that are tuning in live today cold
coffee is saying she's awesome thank you
so this is the boring parts of building
a local I think this is the the the slow
part the more interesting part for me in
building locals are the identities
mm-hmm that come with the locus I say
you're more excited about that stuff huh
yes I am and I did an identity for this
logo for a year so it's not just a logo
yeah I want to show you the identity
mm-hmm before we lose time so let's cut
off the video can you scratch I started
having the most Asian baby right yes I'm
beard okay I see that now right you
rounded off the corner of a beard yeah
okay and did you draw half of it
mirrored over or did you draw each side
a little differently yes the symmetrical
parts yes a mustache and a beard and
then I did the coffee bean beard nice
nice subtle touch in there you guys it's
coffee beard man yeah let's go mm-hmm so
this is the original yes we're gonna go
through like the presentation the this
is the same presentation I provide to my
clients I want everyone watching not to
just see a local improvement I want them
to see how I present logos and
identities to my clients starting with
the old logo of course and then you have
the mood board it includes it's about
Turkish coffee so I got some pictures
about Turkish coffee and Sultan's so
this is Turkish coffee a coffee bean
some Sultan picked
I just want to let you guys know where
the term Sultan comes from it's more or
less the Arabic term for king yeah
exactly and the traditional half is at
our borscht
this is the turbo which is going to be
the music right okay mm-hmm I like how
you think I think you're very conceptual
in your approach in that you're always
looking for an for a way to incorporate
an idea like the coffee bean in the
beard and of course the original had a
coffee cup hat but it's like you're
consistent with that kind of thinking
I'm saying this because I just know more
about your work and your approach so
keep going yeah this is this is the my
process this is what I'm trying to teach
also other interested in the interested
designers I have a process I follow it
every project and it pays off so the
idea is I have to have a solid brief and
then I do a mindmap this is a simple
mind map sometimes they go very more
complex just state the name what is
needed what what do they do and get some
keywords that describes the business in
this case it's just two words and I get
other keywords that describe every each
point mm-hmm okay and then what I do is
I try to sketch combining more or three
a two or three of the of the key words
of God like king crown or maybe a cup
okay mm-hm and this is the brand
personality
I added some touch points sometimes it
most of most of the time you get them
from the grief or from talking to your
clients it directs the direction but
it's like you know identity what is a
market it's like she knows core she's
doing her own version I like it yeah so
this is a biscuit I did on Photoshop
this is the the Victory's version I did
the videos still not refined okay and
then these are the local explorations
mm-hmm can you zoom in a little bit so
we can see them a little bit better yeah
thank you I'm gonna go to the
illustrator fly okay it's much easier
yeah
so here are the explorations yeah what I
did is the the Sultan's face and I tried
to make it make his features a little
bit not angry like but he's a sultan so
he needs to be you serious
right yeah I'm serious yeah yeah exactly
mm-hmm the light is hitting his face
this way and you have mr. Bush his hat
it's also the coffee cup you can see at
the top of it and the the two esteem
mm-hmm and I was trying to change their
color I didn't want them to look like a
priest or it doesn't look good
this way so I tried different approaches
and also I started with a closed face
from this side but then I ended open it
air from this side I say and then I went
back to my book mode board and I found
out that the Sultan's wear jewelry Oh
interesting
she's getting all these notifications
from people on behance following this
live stream he has is going up yeah the
chime it's like you guys follow her
after the show okay I love seeing this I
just want to say one quick thing we're
gonna have to wrap this up pretty soon
but I want to say something I love
seeing the process and how you're
working through this and I just have to
say it's remarkable the transformation
that happens by adding the how do you
say it or Bush paddleboat are Bush thar
Bush how she adds the Sultan's hat and
it doesn't look like a Viking guy
anymore it looks like somebody from the
air
world right yeah highs it's crazy and
the shape matches to the shape matches
and it works and then I like seeing the
different callers that she's designing
and pushing the lighting source which
really makes it more dramatic and some
of you guys are gonna argue and I'm not
gonna get into with you today but some
of you guys argued that logos are icons
like this is it an illustration there's
an icon and there is a point and I don't
know what it is but there's a middle
area that we're not sure I can clearly
look at an illustration say that's an
illustration and I can clearly look at
an icon and say that's an icon but I
think for me in the middle is this thing
that is figurative like she has but it's
still very geometric and symmetrical and
has a really strong sense of design it's
not just following what it looks like
true to life but it's highly stylized
and it's reductive so it's just what you
need to see that's it okay show us how
you apply this and take us home okay
so this is the refinement of the logo
hmm
I added the keep going this is the this
is a rationale I don't about this okay
and then you're gonna find out I wanted
to talk about this I use this jewelry in
the identity mm-hmm I'm gonna show you
later
okay so this is the final logo nice so
use the serif typeface there what tip
what I face is that it's called a ver a
ver a ver yeah AV ER okay but I tweaked
it okay because I didn't want I wanted
the sharp edge sharp edges I see right
over here mm-hmm so I did some tweaks
and this is proxy manova so this is the
primary font yeah this is a secondary
font and this is the main color mm-hmm
yes this is a called golden ratio and
spacing of the logo mm-hmm
I wanted the Sultan to have a cut feel
like he's an oval picture mm-hmm
okay that's another part of the identity
golden area ratio is used only to make
the design more appealing to the eye
proportions yes our proportions I did
the seal design mmm
the seal design is inspired also from
the main logo
it says sultan approved roasted in
Turkey hmm
1950 and the initial initials Justin C
and these are the local variations so
you can use any part by itself
yes e4 logo typography mm-hmm these are
the the fonts and this is how I
represent my projects to my clients I
just need everyone to see this just
relax please
okay any colors okay this is the color
palette and I get my color palettes from
other way color yes same here you can go
to the website color that other bit of
calm you can pick any color palettes you
like and just click Save once you click
Save you get it in your library over
here mm-hmm and you can use the the
color nice yeah I'm a fool I would
screen capture dragon in yeah yeah but
this way you have it forever here in
your life your way is the professional
way what am I talking about I do the
monkey way this is the color palette
yeah I I provide the Pantone colors for
oh my god the father is only answer it's
all right they love you okay started
adding the background colors mm-hmm
where the logo and this is a life
pattern design I did - pattern design
one is the light color it it is inspired
from this story from in his in his
jewellery mm-hmm oh nice
big and small yes honey with this one
and they did another one a dark darker
one spray it from a geometrical abstract
abstract design of a coffee bean mm-hmm
Xavier Lopez saying she's dope she's
dope nice yeah this is a an icon sets
the pattern this is the logo then the
seal design the icon set and they also
the stars are from his jewelry you know
you need everything to be consistent so
complete oh and the grid I love it on
there's a t-shirt or a uniform Wow okay
these are the go just a little bit you
go all the way oh yeah all right okay
let's do this can we jump into it
yep this is the original oh okay
everybody okay hold on hold on go back
to the original logo everybody take a
look at the original and I'm gonna say
some things here when you pick this I
was like oh shoot this is a really nice
logo I mean I was a little nervous for
you I gotta say I was nervous like this
is pretty nice and then show us what you
did hey Wow big difference big
difference I like it okay everybody
everybody is watching three hundred
ninety two of you the audience size has
grown just a little bit so has ideals
following yes is that I did some read
mock-ups I printed all right everybody's
on notice now everybody's unnoticed it's
your house gone if any of the young guns
are paying attention you know what a
attention yeah young guns pay attention
right now
she actually harvested her own beans and
roasted him for this mock which logo do
you prefer do you prefer the original
line drawing or do you prefer what
hadeel has done with the thousand
variations and applications and identity
system which is built which do you
prefer let us know in the comments below
we do have to wrap up the show we have
to help the show it's at that time yes
yes yes I first want to thank both
Marcus and he'll deal for doing this you
guys they're excellent please do look
them up following on Instagram and you
already follow her on be hands but go
ahead and do it let the chimes go crazy
right now look them up Marcus ranch a
deal
Sayed Ahmad right do I say the right
yeah okay okay let's get out of here you
guys if you're sitting there and you
have a case of the FOMO the fear of
missing out the way that you get your
logo critiqued by one of our amazing
team of local therapist is you post it
on Facebook under this pinned post right
here they'll comb through that they'll
pick something sometimes they're looking
for a challenge so don't worry it's not
that your logo is good or bad it's just
because they feel like they'll want to
try something with what you're doing
okay now that we render the video be
sure you guys like comment and subscribe
don't cut to that late thank you very
much Jonah and just big heartfelt thank
to all of our sustaining members the
donation if you will the donation let's
get here thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
you